MARY HIMINKOOL: Hi.
Good morning, everyone.
Good morning and welcome to day
three of Google I/O. Hope
you've had an amazing
time so far.
We are delighted to have you
with us this morning for our
panel, "Designing for the Other
Half: Sexy Isn't Always
Pink." My name is Mary
Himinkool, and I'm the head of
Global Entrepreneurship
Outreach at Google.
Our team looks after all of
Google's partnerships and
programs around the world
to support startups and
entrepreneurs, and we feel very
privileged to work with
and learn from so many amazing
entrepreneurs around the world.
We have five of them
with us here today.
And today we're going to explore
a discussion of really
how to build amazing products
that resonate with both women
and men, how to scale and start
great companies, how to
build community, really an
analysis of the business and
product landscape and
opportunities
around women as well.
So I'd like to start
by introducing
my fantastic panelists.
First we have Tracy Chou,
who is with Pinterest.
And Tracy is a back-end
software engineer at Pinterest.
She was previously at Quora,
where she was an early
engineer there.
She's also had roles at both
Facebook and Google.
Tracy studied at Stanford where
she earned her BS in
Electrical Engineering and her
Master's in Computer Science.
We also have Leah Busque, who is
the founder of TaskRabbit.
Since its founding in 2008, Leah
has scaled TaskRabbit to
over 45 employees, and the
services live in eight
different cities.
Prior to that, Leah was a
software engineer at IBM, and
she's been recognized as one
of the 100 most creative
people in business by Fast
Company, and also one of the
15 women to watch by
Inc. Magazine.
So we're thrilled to
have her with us.
Next to me here is
Margaret Wallace.
Margaret is an active
entrepreneur in the gaming,
technology, and media sectors.
She is the CEO of Playmatics,
which is a New York-based
company focused on rich social
gaming experiences.
And before Playmatics,
Margaret was the
CEO of Rebel Monkey.
She's also spent time at
Shockwave.com, at PF.Magic, at
Mattel and Mindscape.
And she recently created a
very cool game last year,
which is a shadow government
game that lets users run their
own version of a virtual
version of the US.
We're also excited to have
Jess Lee, who is the
co-founder and CEO of Polyvore,
which was voted one
of Fast Company's 50 most
innovative companies in 2012.
Before that, Jess worked at
Google, where she was the
product manager for
Google Maps.
And she has a Bachelor's
in Computer
Science from Stanford.
Jess is also a very talented
artist, and she's an avid
comic book collector.
She has over 1,000
comic books.
We're also delighted to have
Sepi Nasiri with us.
Sepi is the director of all
things offline at Women 2.0.
She's responsible for global
partnerships and for
sponsorships.
And Sepi got her start as a
managing editor of an LA
global magazine.
A fun tidbit about Sepi is
that two years ago she
launched her first app in the
Apple store, and it is the
Date Saver Platinum application,
which gives users
a portable bathroom fan.
So we have to ask her
about that later.
But welcome, all of you.
We're delighted to have you.
And welcome to everybody here.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
So I'd like to start by turning
it over to our great
panelists this morning, and ask
each of you to share with
us a one-minute introduction of
your company and its core
mission, starting with
you, Margaret.
MARGARET WALLACE: Hi.
Good morning, everybody.
It's really great to see
everyone in the room.
My name is Margaret Wallace.
I am a CEO of a company
called Playmatics.
I co-founded Playmatics
with Nick Fortugno.
He's a game designer probably
best known for having designed
"Diner Dash," which I think a
few of us in this room may
have played.
I've been in gaming--
at the intersection of gaming,
tech, and media-- since--
it's kind of not cool to
say it-- since 1996.
And I've worked on all sides
of the equation, on the
publisher sides of technology
companies, I've
raised venture capital.
And Playmatics is a
15-person company
based in New York City.
About a year and a half ago,
we raised some angel
investment to create a game
called "Shadow Government,"
which is a real world political
simulation of the
United States that runs off of
a 30-year-old algorithmic
model called the T21.
But we really focus on
designing engaging--
hopefully engaging--
social games for both
women and men.
And we try not to clone.
So that's sort of a quick
intro of who I am.
Nice to meet everybody
here, too.
TRACY CHOU: Hi, I'm
Tracy Chou.
I'm with Pinterest.
If you haven't used Pinterest
before, it's a place online
where you can collect and find
the images and things that
really inspire you and
that you love.
And we're really hoping to be
a place for discovery on the
web and working on building
that out.
My background is in engineering,
and I really love
working and building consumer
web products.
So I love thinking about the
technical aspects, but also
translating product ideas
into the back ends.
SEPIDEH NASIRI: Good morning.
My name is Sepi Nasiri, and I'm,
as mentioned, director of
all things offline
at Women 2.0.
Women 2.0's mission is to
increase the number of female
founders in technology
startups.
And to do so, we have our online
component, which is our
blog network, and we also have
our offline products,
including our conference
and our events.
LEAH BUSQUE: Hi, everyone.
My name is Leah Busque.
I'm the CEO of TaskRabbit.
TaskRabbit is an online
marketplace where people can
go to outsource small jobs and
tasks to others in their
neighborhood.
So if you need dry cleaning
picked up or groceries
delivered, you can go on
TaskRabbit.com or download our
mobile app, name the price
you're willing to pay to have
a job done, and then we match
you with our network of
hundreds of background-checked
TaskRabbits in your
neighborhood.
Our mission is really
to empower people to
do what they love.
JESS LEE: I'm Jess Lee, the
co-founder and CEO of Polyvore.
Polyvore is a fashion community
site with over 15
million unique visitors
a month.
I guess Mary just outed me as
a comic book nerd and as
someone who loves to draw.
I really wanted to go to art
school when I was growing up,
and my parents told me no,
because they're Asian.
So I ended up studying
computer science.
And I was really excited to come
across Polyvore, because
Polyvore is a place where people
can just mix and match
items they love in a very
artistic way to
create these collages.
So we essentially have a
platform and tools that
empower other people to be
artistic and creative.
So it's something that I'm
really passionate about.
And I think it's sort of akin to
a fashion magazine, except
it's created by a global
community of fashionistas from
all over the world.
Yeah.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Thank you.
Thank you all for joining us.
So I'd like to start
by looking a bit
at the product landscape.
And so, starting with Tracy
with Pinterest.
Tell us about the evolution of
Pinterest and how your users
are interacting with the site.
TRACY CHOU: Sure.
I can give a little
bit of history.
So Pinterest has actually been
around for a few years now.
It was founded--
started getting kicked
off in 2009.
And most people didn't hear
about it until late 2011.
So it's actually quite a long
time of trying to iterate on
the product and get traction
with users.
It's meant to be a general
platform for collecting and
sharing images, and it's
resonated a lot with people
who work in industries that are
very inspiration-driven.
So a lot of architects
were on early.
Like, one of our founders,
who is a designer, was in
architecture school, and so he
found a lot of similarities
between Pinterest and the
physical boards in which he
would be collecting
inspiration.
There's a lot of people
who are doing arts
and crafts on Pinterest.
Just like getting ideas and
thinking about things that
they want to do.
As we've evolved, it's just been
this gradual process of
acquiring a community and
thinking about reaching out to
people, figuring out what makes
the most sense for them,
and responding to
feedback a lot.
I guess--
I'm not sure what else
there is to say.
It's just keep talking
to your community,
seeing what they want.
But there's not too much, so
it's like too mind blowing.
As we've evolved, we've just
been acquiring more and more
people who are interested in
looking at different recipes
that people are pinning,
finding
inspiration for their homes.
So there's a pretty wide ranging
appeal for just like--
it started off with a lot
of women in the Midwest.
But it's starting to find
greater appeal.
MARY HIMINKOOL: And
Tracy, you're on
the engineering side.
So when you guys built the
product, did you design it
specifically with
women in mind?
TRACY CHOU: No.
It's meant to be a
general platform.
So the founding team was
actually three men.
And the team has been majority
men for a long time.
We really want to build
a general platform.
But as any sort of site like--
that focuses on community, who
you seed the community with
will determine a lot of
the early demographic.
Previously, I was at Quora,
which is also meant to be a
general platform for questions
and answers.
But it also started off
being primarily male.
And it just is a function
of who you seed
the community with.
And you can start growing beyond
that initial seed as
you figure out your product.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Thank you.
Thank you.
So speaking of growth and
scale, Leah, I have a
question for you.
So TaskRabbit has scaled rapidly
into eight cities.
And can you share with us what
the trigger points are for you
to know when to invest more
resources and double down in a
specific city, market, or
on a product feature?
What's the inflection
point for you?
LEAH BUSQUE: Yeah,
it's interesting.
When I think back about a year
ago, we were just in a couple
of markets.
And at that time, Boston and
San Francisco were our two
main markets.
We started to dig into our
database and our data, and
really did a deep dive
on who our top
users were at the time.
Who were the top people
posting tasks?
And so in a two-sided
marketplace, we have the Task
Rabbits and we have
the Task Posters.
And so once we did the analysis
of who our top task
posters were in Boston and San
Francisco, we started to see
some trends and some
commonality.
And that was the point where
we learned that our two top
demographics both skewed
slightly female.
The first demo was 25 to
35-year-old young professional
living in an urban
environment.
She was outsourcing things
like, I need help with my
grocery shopping, handyman
services, laundry.
And then the next demographic
up-- it was a jump--
and it was the 35 to 45-year-old
female, typically
a mom with kids, working
full time.
And it wasn't just moms,
because we saw on the
TaskRabbit side a lot of stay
at home moms that were doing
TaskRabbit to bring in income
and bring in money.
And they were out running their
own errands anyway, and
didn't mind picking things
up for people.
So once we had enough data to
really deep dive into our main
core demographics, that's when
we started to make explicit
decisions about design, about
product features, about
implementation that we felt
would cultivate the best user
experience around those
demographics.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Wonderful.
Wonderful.
Margaret.
So gaming is a topic that we
know resonates well with both
men and women.
You have such deep expertise
in the area.
I'm hoping you can share with us
more context and some data
points on the landscape
of gaming.
And are there any patterns
or trends that
have surprised you?
MARGARET WALLACE: Yeah.
So that's a great question.
And Playmatics, we create a
range of IP, whether you're
talking about original IP.
We work with brands.
And we also work a lot in the
growing and contentious field
of gamification, which is sort
of adding game-like dynamics
to non-gaming consumer
services.
And I would say, in gaming in
particular, the biggest change
that I've seen since--
gosh, the '90s, when I was
working on the first ever
virtual pets programs
"Dogs and Cats"--
is, the female audiences
have become a very
core demographic for--
as you probably all know in this
audience-- casual games
and social games.
And I don't know how many people
here are in the gaming
world, but we have a phrase
called whales.
I don't know if it's used in
other industry sectors, but in
the past five years,
free-to-play games have really
become the cash cow,
so to speak, of
social and casual games.
So these are games that are
free to download, free to
play, but to progress and
accelerate your experience or
have a more customizable
experience, one buys virtual
currency and purchases
accelerators or virtual goods
to progress through the game.
And even as recently--
there have been tons
of studies which
show that 1 to 2%--
if you're lucky--
will become purchasing players
in these games.
And there's a study-- there are
many studies, but I found
one which was released by
Papaya Mobile back in
September, 2011, which
identified for their network
that 70% of the whales--
and whales are people
who spend $100 or
more in your game--
are female.
And I can tell you, while there
is a renewed interest in
casual social gaming around
mid-core gaming--
so targeting sort of more
traditional gaming audiences--
that's probably the audience
that my game "Shadow
Government" appeals to--
we all know, from all the
successes of social gaming
companies, especially in the
Bay Area, that 70 to 80% of
their players are females
and often comprise
the majority of whales.
So on the one hand, it's
something to be celebrated and
pointed out that women represent
a huge amount of
purchasing power within social
and casual gaming.
And yet a lot of the social
games that we see on the
market have often been
criticized as being a bit
exploitative, playing on
people's addictions.
And it's just an interesting
question.
What does it mean that the
largest audience for these
games are women?
So on the one hand, it's
a success story.
It's something to call
attention to.
But on the other hand, it kind
of causes me to question how
we monetize our audience,
and what are--
I know ethics can be a bad
word in the world of
entrepreneurship sometimes--
but what are the ethics around
monetizing that audience?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Very
interesting.
So then, general question
for anybody.
What patterns have you seen in
how your user base monetizes?
Any interesting trends
or things of note?
SEPIDEH NASIRI: I think the most
important part is, what
is your user base asking for?
So for Women 2.0, it's mostly
other educational components.
So we launched, last year, a
video about how to build your
own iPhone app.
And within two weeks we had
over 9,000 downloads.
So it shows that if you listen
to your audience or your user
base, you're able to monetize.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Thank
you, Sepi.
And on that note, Women 2.0,
your organization, does
specifically outreach
to women.
So what have you found
to be sticky?
And what are the topics and
themes that resonate most
among your user base?
SEPIDEH NASIRI: Sticky
questions
would be career based.
Women in tech, or women just
general, they're still finding
ways to grow.
And where they would like
to take their career--
particularly because women
have different
responsibilities than men.
And showing that, as a mom, you
can still have a company
and grow your company and
educating them of how to have
a life and work balance
is important.
So those would be the first
questions we get everyday.
And besides that, when you have
decided to build your own
company, then how do
I get funding?
And most importantly, what
Women 2.0 provides is the
platform for networking, for
example, or networking events
where you can build your
network, who is also going to
be the ones who are partnering
with you and
funding you, et cetera.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Great.
So on that point about
community, Jess, Polyvore is
very much about community.
You guys have over 15 million
monthly unique visitors.
Can you share with us your
thoughts on how to build
community among your users,
both women and men?
And how do you solicit feedback
from your community?
JESS LEE: Sure.
So Polyvore is very much rooted
in the community.
We're nothing without our
awesomely talented user base.
They're the people who grab
products from all over the web
and import them into Polyvore.
They're the people who put
together the beautiful
collages and sets, some
of which are--
in terms of aesthetic quality
and taste-- are up there with
the top editors of Vogue.
So I'm very, very proud of the
community that we've built.
It's been about the community
from the very beginning,
partly because--
so I think a good example is,
I actually came out of our
user community.
So I was working at
Google Maps and I
was very happy there.
And then one day my office--
my cube-mate showed me, hey,
check out this site, Polyvore,
that my friend is working on.
And I played with it, and
I was just blown away.
It was sort of like the
perfect mix of art and
technology.
And I was just using it two
to three hours a night.
And then I wrote to the
founder at the time.
And I said, hey,
this is great--
I have some feedback for you.
A lot of complaints, actually.
So I wrote him a long
list of complaints.
And then he wrote back and said,
hey, why don't you come
fix this yourself?
So then I ended up coming
on board at Polyvore.
And so I was already part of
the user community, so I
already had friends
in the community.
And this is before Facebook
Connect existed, so this was
like people who did not
actually know each
other in real life.
But we became friends.
And so ever since then, I've
always stayed in touch with
all those community members.
And we take it very seriously.
Our philosophy around the
community is to always go the
extra mile.
So when people write in, we
take the time to actually
write back.
For our very, very top members--
and some of these
people have been using this
site for like five years,
they're so loyal.
They post their sets to
Facebook, they post their sets
to Twitter.
They're the people who have
actually helped us grow,
because they tell their friends
about the site.
So I think a good example
of how we listen to our
community--
we recently had a meetup.
We try to actually bring
our members in
every once in a while.
So on Friday, we had a meetup
with about 11 members.
Flew some in from-- there was
one girl from Brazil,
Wisconsin, Hawaii.
These people have dedicated
years of their life.
Like one girl had been using
the site since she was 13
years old, and now she's 18.
So she kind of grew
up on Polyvore.
So we brought them all in and
we just really tried to show
them how much we appreciate
them and how
much we love them.
So we pampered them.
We had a little makeup station
for them to get makeovers
sponsored by Bare Essentials.
And then we did a couple
of sessions with them.
One, we had our designers walk
through how we roll out
changes on the site, because--
as I'm sure a lot of people
know-- when you change
something on a site that people
are used to, they get
really mad.
It's called change
aversion, right?
It doesn't matter if it's a good
change or a bad change.
Oftentimes the initial
reaction is I
hate it, it's different.
So we walk them through how
we look at that process.
And part of it is we actually
count all the comments on the
blogs from our users.
And sometimes we change
something and get 500 comments.
So we count all of them, and
then we measure how many were
positive and negative.
And I think what's special
about our community is
sometimes there's a lot of
negative comments, and then
someone's like, hey,
leave them alone.
They're working really hard.
They answered my email
immediately.
So it's good to have a
community, because they in
turn defend you when something
goes wrong.
And we've made mistakes, and
we've rolled them back.
People are generally
very understanding.
But we flew out these members.
We showed them a good time.
We previewed a couple of new
features with them, got a lot
of feedback.
And it was really special.
The special day for them to
meet each other as well.
There are a couple of
cool stories that
came out of the community.
I found out that one
of our members is--
she met a girl on the site who
she's now inviting to her
wedding that she'd never
met before, which
I thought was pretty--
I would never invite someone I'd
never met to my wedding.
And then it turned out that
three of the members had
actually been--
and we didn't know this
beforehand-- but they had been
inspired to actually go to
fashion school and graphic
design school because of all
their time spent on Polyvore.
They really realized how good
they were at graphic design.
And so now they're
pursuing careers.
That's really meaningful.
It's really meaningful
for us, for the team.
And then it's a good opportunity
for us to really
show them how much we appreciate
them, and then in
turn to get feedback
from them.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Extension
of that question
to any of the panelists.
Any key lessons learned or
insights on how to engage user
feedback and incorporate
it into your products?
LEAH BUSQUE: I can start.
So I think the key is just make
it really, really easy
for your users to give
you feedback.
So at TaskRabbit we have
24/7 customer service.
We have chat.
We have phones.
We're on email all the time.
In the product flow, we also
have little hooks where people
can easily leave their comments
and feedback.
And I think the key is, when we
see something that hasn't
gone quite right, or that we
could improve, we'll follow up
with the user with a phonecall
or an email.
We really try to understand
how we can make sure that
every time someone has
an experience on
TaskRabbit, it's amazing.
And if it's not of the highest
quality, then we're
immediately digging in
to figure out why
and what we can improve.
And then the second thing I'd
say, along the lines of what
Jess mentioned with product, is
we have weekly user testing
sessions or user research
sessions.
And basically every week,
Thursdays, we have a group of
users come in.
We don't know what we're going
to show them every week.
Sometimes the marketing team
will run by some messaging or
new ad campaigns with them.
Sometimes the designers will
show them what they're working
on, going forward from a user
experience standpoint.
Sometimes we just have questions
about pricing or
what they want to see more of.
And so I think having a
consistent pattern of a way to
get in front of your users
all the time is
really, really important.
MARGARET WALLACE: And just to
jump in really quickly on the
gaming front.
Game designers always engage
in this debate.
How much should one be
led by the community?
How much can the community
anticipate design?
So in gaming it's always a fine
line between listening to
the community and responding,
but also taking those leaps of
faith or incorporating that
magic sauce that goes into
making hopefully great games.
However, I think any of us
who've been in gaming the past
few years-- especially in the
social gaming sector-- know
how much analytics have really
risen to the forefront, almost
to a reductive fashion where
game designers will come up
with an engagement loop for
a game or some kind of
monetization loop, and before
that even gets implemented,
that gets run through a whole
series of analytics.
Real time analytics--
we use a package called Swerve
which is really wonderful.
But the larger the social game
company, the less and less
things are left up to chance,
because it really becomes
about spreadsheets.
So it has its benefits, but
I think it also has its
drawbacks on the
creative front.
JESS LEE: I do think you also
have to figure out the right
kinds of questions to
ask your community.
What we've found is when you
ask, hey, what do you think of
this idea or this feature?
They'll say, yeah, that
sounds really great.
So that's not as useful as
saying, here, look at this
actual prototype of this.
Tell us what you think.
Can you complete this
given task?
So you really have to--
and you also have to listen not
just to what users say but
what they do.
So rolling out an A/B
experiment, where you try the
new feature.
You can either-- so the
process that we use is
oftentimes we test with a top
group of VIP members, sort of.
And then we get their feedback,
a qualitative feedback.
And then we move to like
a 5% or 10% experiment.
You need to figure out what
sample size actually makes
sense for you.
And then we actually
measure some of the
metrics we care about.
And then we roll it out to
the whole community.
And then we know that
if it's a big
change they may complain.
So then we have in reserve some
other things that we may
roll out soon afterwards that
will sort of mitigate the
negativity.
And then we're very
quick to respond.
Like, as soon as the launch
happens, everyone is watching
the blog post and monitoring
for comments.
Because there's definitely
things we don't think of.
And then we try to
implement those
things as fast as possible.
And what we find is that our
community actually notices.
They say, hey, I noticed that
that changed immediately after
I reported it.
I saw that you added that
commenting feature I asked for
a day afterwards.
That's so cool.
Thank you.
So I think it's good to be
really, really responsive
right after your launch, too.
It's not done when
it's launched.
MARY HIMINKOOL: A really good
insight, definitely.
TRACY CHOU: I have one thing
to add which is, on the
company side, it's also very
important to dedicate
resources to community in terms
of employees, like the
head count.
At Pinterest we have six or
seven community team people
out of a total of
50 right now.
And they are very
empowered to--
I mean, they have a lot
of responsibility.
And we have them sit with
product and engineering when
we're making design decisions.
So it's not just responding to
new product features when
we're about to roll them out.
We have community team sitting
with us and saying, I'm
getting a lot of reports from
users that they really like
this or they really
don't like this.
So we should incorporate it
into the new designs that
we're rolling out.
So just making community a
priority within the company is
very important.
And the other thing is having
a good system to track what
the community is saying.
So we track different types
of tickets in Zendesk.
And we have graphs of how many
tickets we're getting for
different types of issues.
And that just helps us to know
what people care about in a
very quantitative but also
qualitative way.
MARY HIMINKOOL: So on that point
of building a great team
within the company and scaling
a great company.
How do you guys approach hiring
and building a team?
And what is your interview
process like?
LEAH BUSQUE: So at TaskRabbit,
we've kind of honed in on a
process over the course of
about 12 months or so.
And so whoever we're
interviewing, whatever
candidate comes in, typically
they initially do a phone call
with Ryan, who's our
talent scout.
And then they come in and they
meet the hiring manager, but
then they also meet a
few other key team
members on the team.
And if that goes well, they'll
come in for a second round of
interviews with a wider group.
And this round of interviews is
really important because we
pick people across teams
and across functions.
And so we're not only looking
for folks that have various
skill sets and can actually do
the job really well, but also
folks that are going to work
well and are a great culture
fit across the entire company.
And then from there, something
that I've always been very
adamant and passionate about
is, I don't care how big we
get, I want to meet every
single person that comes
through the door.
And we'll see how long that
scales to, I'm not sure.
But we have this sort of founder
round interviews.
And it's not really set up so
that I have the power to say
yea or nay on someone.
That's not what it is at all.
It's actually really important
to me for those candidates to
know that I want to know who
they are, and that I am a
resource to them, and that
I want to be engaged
with them as well.
And it doesn't matter what
team they're on or what
they're working on.
It's important to me to have
that sort of open door policy,
and that starts as part of the
candidate interview process.
So that's worked really
well for us.
But we're continuing to change
and iterate it over time.
SEPIDEH NASIRI: So we have
similar, actually, ways of
interviewing when we add
someone to our team.
One of the main, I guess, focus
for us is personality.
Our team currently has three
main people, which includes
our CEO and co-founder Shaherose
Charania, and Angie
Chang, and then myself.
And what we do is we always have
this philosophy, can you
share a pillow with this
person if you have to?
We do work late.
And we consider everyone
who we add to
our team as a family.
You eat with them, you sometimes
have to share that
pillow in the office.
So making sure that we all have
the same chemistry and
we're all focused on the same
goals is important.
And we do have teams
across the country
internationally as well.
So we do chat with them and make
sure that they feel with
us that they're included.
MARGARET WALLACE: Some of the
people at Playmatics are folks
that I've worked with in
previous companies.
One guy who was the original
programmer on the first "Diner
Dash" game, I've known and
worked with him for 12 years.
And so I'm really fortunate to
have good people that you keep
with you along the way.
But we're a small,
scrappy startup.
And so we rely largely on
not only referrals--
and if you're lucky enough to
know a lot of people, it's
pretty easy to pull in resources
as you need them.
My co-founder teaches at a local
university in the game
design program.
So in terms of fresh talent,
we're always meeting and
recruiting fresh talent.
We have something called the
camping test, kind of like the
pillow test.
Can I go camping with
this person?
Because really, at the end of
the day-- and I've made this
mistake before.
I've made fewer and fewer
mistakes in hiring than when I
first started out, where
I made a bunch.
One kind of thing I've learned
is culture and cultural fit.
It doesn't matter if this person
is a superstar, if they
are the Einstein of whatever
area they're focusing on, if
they cannot work with other
people, when you're a
15-person company, it's just
not going to work.
And it's going to really
sour the morale of
the rest of the office.
So I've learned, and my
co-founder have learned, we've
been really lucky just bringing
in good people,
bringing in bright people.
And if there is a problem,
just really addressing it
immediately.
Because when one runs a startup,
as you can imagine,
it's the little mistakes that
you don't think of, that six
months or three months down the
line that you just think,
oh, why didn't I act sooner?
So that's kind of our process.
Everybody gets to meet just
about everyone else.
But my co-founder and I are
the final decision makers.
We're a small company.
We have to be stealth
and scrappy.
So it kind of works
out like that.
We do have pretty good diversity
on the team, which
I'm pretty proud of.
And it's really largely because
the applicants that
come to us are from diverse
backgrounds.
MARY HIMINKOOL: So everybody
remember the camping test and
the pillow test.
I love to talk about the process
of fund-raising, as
funding is obviously a very
important component of scaling
a business.
Any insights from you guys
on the process, how you
approached it, what your
considerations were?
MARGARET WALLACE: Oh, I'm
sorry, I don't mean to--
just really quickly.
It always takes longer than
you think it does.
If the money is too easy
to come by, that
should be a red flag.
If the money is too hard to come
by, you keep getting the
same answers, that should be
potentially a red flag.
It's a diligent process.
It's a process of constantly
refining and improving.
Like I said, I've successfully
raised venture capital, I've
unsuccessfully raised it, and
I've successfully raised angel
investment.
And every single meeting that
one has with potential
investors is a chance
to learn.
So the biggest point of advice
I would give to anyone in the
audience is, when you have these
meetings, even meetings
that are quote throwaway
meetings with C-level people
that you may not be interested
in, C-tier people you may not
interested in working with,
write everything down.
You'll find that the same
questions often bubble up, and
those are things you need to
address in order to probably
successfully fundraise
in the future.
JESS LEE: So at Polyvore we've
raised three rounds, although
the total sum is
not that high.
And so A, B, and C are actually
very different.
So for the A, we raised about
$2.5 million from Benchmark
Capital in 2007.
And I think in the
beginning when--
it could be seed,
it could be A--
the easiest way to raise
is to have traction.
That's kind of obvious, and
also very difficult.
But that was the approach that
we took at the time.
We already built--
the site was already built and
sort of a little bit on its
way, so it became an easier
sort of sell.
The Series B was in 2009 in the
summer, and this was when
the economy was like ehh.
So a much more difficult
time to raise.
Even though we were doing well,
it was just much harder.
So we were hitting Sand
Hill Road and
talking to all the VCs.
And I think through that process
we learned--- we honed
sort of what our deck
should look like.
Like, what are the key things
you really need to cover,
which are product,
market and team.
And of the three, it actually
turns out, I think, that
market is really important.
If your product is not solving
a large enough market, then
you won't get certain kinds
of VCs to invest.
So we successfully raised our B
from Matrix Capital-- about
$5.6 million in 2009.
And then our C, which we just
closed in January--
this was before the Facebook
IPO, which I've heard has
affected valuations.
But that one was, I guess,
again, different market
conditions.
So this was after a lot of
companies had raised a lot of
money in 2011 and the
market was-- the
climate was very good.
So that was a much easier
round to raise.
And then at that point
we had more traction.
So we closed a $14 million
round in January.
All very different.
So our C we raised from DAG,
a more-- sort of a standard
Silicon Valley type VC--
great firm, and then Goldman
Sachs, which is very--
not traditionally--
I think we were like the eighth
company they had ever
invested in, so very different
sort of due diligence process.
Due diligence is obviously
much more strict in the C
stage or the later stage, but
Goldman Sachs is especially
strict because they're
a big public company.
So they have a lot of process
they have to go through to get
the money approved.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Great.
Great.
So we have a lot of
entrepreneurs here in the
audience with us today.
What advice do you ladies have
for startups or companies who
are looking on how to design
with women in mind?
And how targeted is
your marketing?
LEAH BUSQUE: I would say just
general advice is find great
mentors, advisers, people that
you can surround yourself with
that you can use as a sounding
board, bounce around ideas.
If you feel like going into your
idea or company, you know
exactly who the demographic is,
then find an adviser or
mentor that you feel
matches that.
So you can use them to do a
lot of research early on.
But then I would say don't
assume you know who you're
building for until you actually
build it and get
those users and start looking
through the data.
And that's going to tell you and
influence your decisions
about how to move forward.
So I think it's more about
constantly just iterating on
customer feedback in your
community, rather than
assuming you know exactly
who you're designing
for to begin with.
TRACY CHOU: A couple points.
One is if you can try to build
up your intuition as much as
possible early on, like
Leah was saying.
If you can get mentors or get
people to come in so you
understand generally what
direction you want your
product to go in, that's most
important as you're getting
started and you don't have
any data to work with.
And users aren't going to
tell you what they want.
And one way also to--
one hack to get better intuition
about the products
that you're trying to build is
getting people from those
demographics into your company
working there.
If you can hire female
engineers, that helps.
If you can hire female product
managers, people who are
actually using the products,
they're going to be there.
And that feedback loop is just
so much faster than having to
go out and do user research or
run some A/B tests and wait
for two weeks to get the data.
If you just have someone who's
there and can say, like, I'm
part of this demographic, and
this is what I like, and this
is what I think a lot of other
people will like, it's just
much easier to build
those products.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Thank you.
In just a couple minutes,
we'll start
taking audience questions.
So if anybody has questions in
mind, please go ahead and line
up and we'll take them in
just a few minutes.
So a question then about-- a
lot of your products have
spread very virally.
And in addition to this organic
growth, how do you
approach proactive marketing
to the extent that you do?
LEAH BUSQUE: So for us, 75% of
our users come in via word of
mouth, NPR, just general
awareness.
So that's awesome.
Because it's free channels.
And it is very organic
and viral.
But when we think about money
that we do spend on marketing,
whether it's SEM or display or
re-targeting, we try to get
very targeted about
the demographic.
And so we'll do partnerships,
for instance, with mom's
groups, or with community school
organizations, PTAs.
So we know that those are
our top heavy users.
And so finding the right outlets
of where those users
are is really important if
you're going to spend.
TRACY CHOU: One thing for
Pinterest is, even though we
haven't done a lot of marketing
per se, we are
pretty strategic about
what press will do.
So if you're located in Silicon
Valley and you're a
startup here, it's very easy
to get a lot of coverage by
the tech blogs.
If that's not where your users
are, there's not really much
point in going to the tech
blogs, unless you're trying to
do recruiting.
But for us, we tend to do press
or let people write
about us, if it's in some
publication where we will be
the only tech piece.
And we try to be where our
users are going to be.
So if we're trying to get more
people in home decor, then
going to the magazines about
interior decoration makes
sense, or going to the
mommy bloggers,
those all make sense.
But not as much TechCrunch.
JESS LEE: So we don't actually
have a marketing team, but we
do do marketing through word of
mouth through our community.
And there's a standard, build
a great product and then
they'll talk about it.
There's always that.
But on top of that, we actually
try to cultivate
great opportunities for
our community members.
So the fashion industry
is a very top
down kind of industry.
And Polyvore has a very
bottoms up approach.
We're empowering all these
fashionistas all over the
world to sort of have
a voice in fashion.
And so we've tried to create
opportunities with our
advertisers.
So they often end up being
revenue generating
opportunities for us as well,
which is kind of nice.
But some examples are, we
partnered with Rebecca
Minkoff, who's a handbag
designer, an independent
accessories designer.
And she wanted to promote her
morning-after clutch, which is
her most famous sort of
bag that she makes.
And so we put together a
campaign on Polyvore where we
asked our members to design
their own version of her bag,
and they could put studs on it
and sort of pimp it out.
And we got over 6,000
submissions from our community.
And then the winner, who turned
out to be this girl
named Dee in Detroit, she got
to travel to New York for
Fashion Week and sit in Rebecca
Minkoff's show and
watch her creation-- her bag
actually got produced and it
went down the runway--
she got to see that.
She had never been to
New York before.
She'd never been to
Fashion Week.
And so for her that was
a major opportunity.
And the bag got produced and
sold in Saks, so doing those
kinds of things, like, she's
going to remember
that for a long time.
Our community remembered it.
Everyone was so excited.
They were so supportive
of her.
The bag was named after her, it
was called the Dee Clutch,
and it actually sold out.
So the things like that, I
think, when you can cultivate
things around your members and
have them talk about you,
that's much better than talking
about yourself.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Absolutely.
So first audience question.
AUDIENCE: So has it been a
problem for something like
TaskRabbit at all, or
how big a problem
for nonstandard uses?
Like, someone putting a task
up to maybe have a lot of
people do reviews of a site or
a game, or to get promotion
and sort of Mechanical Turk kind
of artificial promotion?
Is that-- any kind of outside
uses like that--
is that a big problem?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Also, audience
members, we'd love for you to
introduce yourselves.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
Jason Sackett.
LEAH BUSQUE: Hi, Jason.
Thanks for your question.
So it hasn't been
a huge problem.
We've seen it on a
couple occasions.
I think, for us, the key is we
ask our task posters to put in
credit card information
upfront.
And we use that to verify
identity and keep our
TaskRabbit safe.
And we pre-authorize cards.
So that rules out a
lot of the spam.
But then on top of that, we
also have what we call a
self-policing community.
So anyone in the community can
flag a task as inappropriate,
and then it's immediately looked
at by our internal
operations team and taken down
if it's deemed inappropriate.
So we haven't really come across
a lot of those types of
issues yet.
Maybe they're coming,
I don't know.
But that's how we've
handled it to date.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was thinking
more about the ethical
considerations of media and
games and these sort of
addictive loops and stuff.
And this particular task is not
necessarily inappropriate.
It depends on what's
inappropriate.
So there's a lot of room there,
a lot of gray area.
MARGARET WALLACE: Yes, and that
is the unspoken secret.
A lot of those social mobile
games kind of work their
numbers that way by finding
people to write reviews.
And not necessarily
using TaskRabbit,
but it's a big concern.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Pablo Perez.
I have a question for
Tracy of Pinterest.
But I'd also like to hear
everybody else's opinion, too.
Pinterest, it sounds like, it
took a couple of years for it
to really take off.
At what point was that tipping
point where you just saw it
really accelerate?
And did social networks
play into it?
Or was it the users?
TRACY CHOU: Really
great question.
Thank you.
We've asked ourselves this
very same question.
We don't know the answer.
So if you're just looking at the
numbers and the shape of
the graph, it was sometime last
spring or summer where it
started to pick up a
little bit more.
And there were huge growth
spikes at the end of last year
and beginning of this year.
We don't actually really
know what they were.
From the beginning, Facebook
and Twitter were already
around, so those distribution
channels already existed.
And there was no particular
event that precipitated, like
an inflection point.
I think it's just keeping at
it, and eventually, if you
have the right growth rate,
it will start picking up.
LEAH BUSQUE: Yeah.
I would add, I think, for
TaskRabbit and a lot of other
companies, it's so much
about timing.
Sometimes the consumer mindset
just needs time to develop.
And I started TaskRabbit back
in the end of 2008.
It was September, 2008.
And actually when I launched
it, right when the stock
market was crashing, and all
these people were getting laid
off, and I just quit my job at
IBM, which I was starting to
rethink at the time.
And what was interesting is that
ended up being a really
great time to launch a platform
like TaskRabbit,
because it gave people a way
to make money, to make ends
meet, to get by.
And then it grew from there.
So I think so much of it is
just the market needs to
develop and how the
market changes.
And then the consumer mindset
tends to shift as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Tommy.
So I have a question
about Google+.
So I hear that Google+
has a heavy skew
towards male audience.
I was curious, do you have any
insight into what about their
product makes it heavily skew
towards male as opposed to
female, and how could
they improve?
MARGARET WALLACE: We
use Google Hangouts
for our board meetings.
And so we use Google+
pretty heavily.
And I really--
I think that, personally, my
opinion as a user is it
probably just needs a UI
overhaul, and kind of more--
it's really, I guess, maybe the
original audience it also
kind of appealed to and
revolved around.
But we use it all the time.
I love it.
I think Hangouts is
revolutionary.
Probably a UI thing.
It's a UI thing.
MARY HIMINKOOL: I guess an
extension of that question,
though, for each of
your products.
Do you notice how important is
UI design when catering to a
specific sector of
an audience?
JESS LEE: So I like that the
panel title is like, it's not
always pink.
So if you look at Polyvore,
which is definitely targeted
at women, that we don't
support menswear
on the site at all.
Our UI is actually very spare
and white and black.
If you took out all the sets
and you looked at just the
elements we provide, you
might even say that
it's kind of masculine.
We use Gotham font.
It's just very spare.
And the reason for that is we
want to put our brand and our
UI in the background, and
put the community in the
foreground.
Because they already make really
gorgeous layouts and
sets that express
who they are.
So we don't want to
compete with that.
We don't want to put like a
pink or a blue or anything
else that might distract from
what they're already doing.
So I don't think it's actually
necessary to have a
particularly feminine
visual design in
order to attract women.
And about Google+, I
have one theory.
It is just a theory, but
I think the seed of any
community is very,
very important.
Polyvore was seeded with women
on fashion forums.
I think Google+ was actually
seeded with Google employees.
So it was tech, and honestly,
mostly male.
So I think that's part
of how it grew.
So those people invited their
friends, which-- and then I
think that's sort
of the route.
Whereas if you look at Facebook
started at colleges.
So like cool kid at college
or, I don't
know, maybe not cool.
Ivy league kids at college.
Yeah.
And then MySpace, I
think, probably
started with, like, music.
And so it's all about
the seed.
And I think the seed for Google+
was just different.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Thank you.
Next question?
AUDIENCE: My name is A.J.,
I'm from Montreal.
So I am actually really sad to
hear that Polyvore only has
female clothing.
And I was going to try it out.
And actually, yeah, maybe
that's some constructive
criticism for you.
So my question is actually--
so women are clearly, like, a
minority in the tech industry
in that there's fewer of them.
How do you feel about the
representation of women in the
tech industry?
We've been talking a
lot about your very
inspirational stories.
And that's really inspiring
for me.
But I want to know about your
thoughts on the way that women
are represented.
And also, are you targeting
other minorities in your
design processes?
JESS LEE: I would love to add
menswear one day to Polyvore.
But our philosophy has always
been do a few things well,
like a very, very narrow focus
on a few things that we really
want to nail women's
fashion first.
But I'd love to expand to other
categories at some point.
So women in tech in general.
So I remember when--
I think it was the year after
I graduated from Stanford.
The Computer Science department
had a t-shirt that
said Stanford Computer
Science.
And it was--
I guess it was an unofficial
t-shirt, but it was like nine
guys and one girl, like
stick figures.
And it was really true.
I remember around in my CS
class, and I could name all
the other girls, because there
were just so few of them.
So I realized that.
And then I graduated and
then I went to Google.
And I was very, very lucky
that Google is a very
equitable place.
It's all about meritocracy.
And I think that's actually one
of the great things about
tech in general.
It is more meritocratic, maybe,
than other industries.
But I was very lucky to have
key female mentors.
My first boss at Google was
Marissa Mayer, who's amazing.
And I was just very lucky.
So also my mom is
an entrepreneur.
She ran sort of her own--
she's an interpreter,
Japanese-English interpreter.
And she ran sort of
her home office.
I had a lot of female
role models.
So I figured that the best thing
that I could do to give
back is probably just
help mentor.
And it's actually not even
just specific to women.
I don't usually speak on a lot
of panels about designing for
women, or women in tech.
But what I found is the most
useful thing is actually just
when entrepreneurs are
starting out and have
questions, just taking
the time to meet--
say yes to every coffee.
And just a little
bit of advice.
Because I remember all the
people who really helped me
very early on at Polyvore.
There were people--
the Frenzy team let us squat
in their office for like a
year without paying any rent.
So we tried to do the same.
We paid it forward.
We had another company squat
with us for six months.
So just giving back a little
bit of yourself, I think,
makes all the difference
in the world, both
for women and men.
SEPIDEH NASIRI: I think
also bringing
awareness, such as today.
We have a panel of women here
talking about who they are,
what they have achieved.
You don't see that
quite often.
And when you don't have
those role models for
you to watch out--
OK, I can be the next generation
of entrepreneur, I
can build my successful company,
et cetera, et cetera,
then we don't grow up to have
that passion to be the next
entrepreneur or successful
individual.
For me, the same-- my dad
is as an entrepreneur.
So I had that privilege to see
what I could be someday,
whether studying technology, or
being an engineer, or just
a founder and just creating
something.
And having no limits
to who I can be.
And so Google, as mentioned, has
been trying to do that and
is successful.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Thank you.
Well, I think we just have
a few minutes left.
So what I would love is if the
next two audience members
could both ask their questions,
and then we can
answer them as a group.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Anthony Bowles, senior web
dev at Shop It To Me.
Jess, you alluded to how
data-driven decisions are
built into your product
process.
Margaret, you've dropped
Swerve as a
tool that you're using.
Tracy, you mentioned A/B
testing, but you also talked
about intuition.
So I'm curious if I could get
some information from you
about your process in managing
the priorities and the
features that you think,
on the one hand,
are going to be great.
But then you need to also have
data behind the decisions that
are going into which features
you are going to roll out to
five, 10, X percent
of your user base.
So certainly we, as a company
of 17 people, do not have a
dearth of ideas of things
we'd love to do.
But with the limited number of
resources of engineering, it's
tough to tackle all those.
So if any of you have something
that you're
passionate about and you'd
love to share with the
community about how you manage
the product to engineering,
making sure you give them the
features that you think are
going to be game changers for
your respective entities.
LEAH BUSQUE: I'll answer it.
I actually have a very
timely example.
Because we're in the middle of
this A/B test right now.
And it's a new task form that
we've been testing.
And we wanted to really simplify
the user experience.
And we kept hearing from users
as they would come in every
week that, oh, it's too hard
to post a task, and there's
too many questions.
And so we really tried
to make it simple.
And we came up with this
gorgeous design.
It's just really, really
pleasing and completely
different from our current
task form.
And we rolled it out in
three categories.
Shopping, delivery, and other.
Just sort of a catch-all.
And we A/B tested it in
those categories.
And so we've been running
the test now.
We thought we'd run it for a
couple weeks, and we'd get
enough data to make a call which
way we wanted to go.
We've been running it for
like six weeks now.
And I just talked to Seema,
who's our director of product.
And she's like, I have some
sad news for you.
And I said, Oh my god.
What happened?
And she's like, the simple
shopping form, the simple
test, it's failing.
It's just not working.
And it was such a struggle,
because myself, the team,
everyone wanted it
to work so badly.
And you have to live and
die by the data.
It doesn't work.
And so it's sad that we ran the
tests and we had the one,
the A test that we wanted to
work, but it just doesn't.
And so now it's time to
just kind of cut our
losses and move on.
So I would say live and
die by the data.
But also have that qualitative
research going on an ongoing
basis that you can get
feedback with.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Thank
you very much.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Dan.
You've talked a bit about how
the seed community seems to
determine how the community
ends up
ultimately turning out.
And I was kind of curious if
you think that's how it's
always going to be.
Like I remember reading a few
weeks ago about Reddit.
They initially seeded Reddit
with a bunch of articles that
they wanted to see the
community support.
And so, is this something
that you could
eventually move away from?
Or does your initial seed really
determine the entire
lifespan of your community?
TRACY CHOU: It doesn't have to
determine the entire lifespan.
I think you have to
start somewhere.
And if you can do well there,
then you can start figuring
out what are the adjacent areas
to move into, and grow
from there.
I'm sure when Wikipedia
started it was not a
comprehensive collection
of articles
about all topics ever.
But they started off where they
were strong and could
move into different areas.
I saw this at Quora where Quora
started off with lots of
questions about startups in
tech in Silicon Valley.
They ran some analysis a couple
months ago, and they
were just looking at most
uploaded answers
in different topics.
And there is now six very
strong topic areas.
So one of them was still
startups in tech, but there
was also food.
There was also screenwriting
and Hollywood.
There's politics.
And so you can be strategic
about branching out into
different areas.
And we've been seeing the same
thing for Pinterest, where we
started off with more women,
and there is a certain
demographic that we're
in within the US.
But we're starting to expand
internationally, and the
gender split there is much more
even in the places we've
rolled out to in the Spanish
speaking countries.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MARY HIMINKOOL: So
last question,
some parting thoughts.
We've talked a lot about how
we've all been influenced by
mentors, by the community.
What is the most valuable piece
of feedback that you've
received as an entrepreneur that
you'd like to pass on?
And what's next for you?
What's top of mind for
you right now?
MARGARET WALLACE: I would say
the most valuable experience
I've had as an entrepreneur--
I feel fortunate in some ways,
because I've had such great
experiences working in tech
and media and gaming.
Point to an earlier question--
we do design our products with
gender but also racial
diversity in mind.
I was just in Singapore
a few weeks ago.
And the exploding game community
coming out of
Indonesia was shocking.
But the thing I'm focusing on
now is our game "Shadow
Government," perpetuating it in
as many markets as we can.
And the best piece of advice
I've ever received is accept
failure swiftly and
gracefully.
Don't wallow on it.
Move on.
People might try to drag you
back down in, not even
intentionally.
But be like, oh--
don't even accept it.
Just pick yourself up and
move on and keep going.
[APPLAUSE]
JESS LEE: I have--
I think there's two things.
One is--
and it's almost the philosophy
of our company.
It's do a few things well.
Especially in the early days, it
might be tempting to build
out your prototype with every
bell and whistle that you've
ever thought of.
But really think about what that
core most important thing
is, and just be exceptional at
that one thing first, then add
that second thing.
Because otherwise you're
going to--
it's also difficult just to
analyze your results.
So do a few things well.
And I think that applies to
all parts of your company.
And the other piece
is very similar.
It's basically just
don't give up.
It's easy to look at the
companies that you read about
in TechCrunch and think, wow,
everyone is doing so amazingly.
But what you don't see is sort
of like the blood, sweat, and
tears underneath.
You also don't read about all
the companies that are
struggling.
Right?
Like, for every one company in
TechCrunch that seems to be an
overnight success, there's like
99,000 others that are
still working at it.
And you may think that,
aw, I'm so far--
I'm not that company.
But just keep going.
It's common to make mistakes.
It's common to hire
the wrong people.
All the great companies have
made all the same mistakes
that you're probably making.
So, yeah.
SEPIDEH NASIRI: One advice I
would be able to give you guys
all is don't marry yourself
to one idea.
You have an overall vision, but
your products may change,
or it may merge and grow.
So just focusing on one thing
that you thought first, you
might get lost and your user
base might move on if they
don't see a growth.
LEAH BUSQUE: The best piece of
advice I ever got was from one
of my mentors, Scott Griffith,
who is the CEO of Zipcar.
And he said to me-- this is
what got me to leave IBM.
He said, Leah, I
love your idea.
I think you're on
to something.
I think you should see how
far you can take it.
And he kept saying to me, see
how far you can take it.
And so that's what I continue
to do on a daily basis.
And I think if you can not get
overwhelmed, maybe, by this
sort of big picture and all the
stuff that you need to do,
but just think about pushing it
forward every single day,
that eventually you'll have a
company and it'll be sort of
snowballing away.
TRACY CHOU: My one thing is
to always be improving.
So just continually be improving
yourself and your
company and your product.
That's about it.
If you're always improving,
you're in pretty good shape.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Well, you're all
are remarkably talented.
And we really appreciate you
taking the time to share your
insights with us.
Have a wonderful rest of
the Google I/O day, and
thank you very much.
MARGARET WALLACE: Thank you.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]